algunas de las imágenes más detalladas
del universo profundo.
Pero si tratan de usar el Hubble para crear una imagen del cielo,
se necesitarán 13 millones de imágenes distintas,
o cerca de 120 años, para completarla una sola vez.
Esto nos lleva a nuevas técnicas
y nuevos telescopios.
Telescopios muy sensibles
para adentrarse en el universo profundo,
pero también telescopios
de visión amplia
para capturar el cielo lo más rápidamente posible,
como el Gran Telescopio para Rastreo Sinóptico, o LSST.
Posiblemente el nombre más aburrido
para uno de los más fascinantes experimentos
en la historia de la astronomía.
Es un buen ejemplo, por si hubiera dudas,
de que nunca se debe permitir a un científico o a un ingeniero
poner nombres a nada, ni siquiera a sus hijos.
(Risas)
Estamos construyendo el LSST.
Esperamos comenzar a captar datos a finales de esta década.
Les mostraré cómo creemos
que va a cambiar nuestra visión del universo,
porque una imagen tomada con el LSST
equivale a 3 000 imágenes
del telescopio espacial Hubble,
donde cada imagen cubre tres grados y medio del firmamento
o siete veces el diámetro de la luna llena.
Pero ¿cómo se capturan imágenes a esta escala?
Bueno, construyendo la cámara digital más grande del mundo
con la misma tecnología actual de las cámaras de nuestros móviles,
o cualquier cámara digital comprada en una tienda,
pero con un diámetro de unos 1,7 metros;
más o menos lo que mide un Volkswagen Beetle,
y con una imagen de unos tres mil millones de píxeles.
Para ver una sola imagen del LSST
a máxima resolución,
se necesitarían unas 1 500 pantallas de televisión de alta definición.
Esta cámara estará fotografiando el cielo
cada 20 segundos,
escaneándolo constantemente.
Cada tres días obtendremos un mapa completo
del cielo estrellado de Chile.
Durante su vida útil,
el telescopio detectará 40 mil millones de estrellas y galaxias.
Por primera vez
el número de cuerpos celestes detectados
superará al de los habitantes de la Tierra.
Bueno, puedo explicar esto
midiéndolo en terabytes y petabytes,
o contando miles de millones de objetos.
Para dar una idea de la cantidad de datos
que producirá esta cámara,
es como la totalidad de las charlas TED grabadas hasta la fecha,
reproducidas simultáneamente, 24 horas al día,
7 días a la semana, durante 10 años.
Y el esfuerzo de procesar esta información
equivale a buscar en todas esas charlas
una nueva idea, un concepto nuevo,
mirando cada trozo de video
para ver qué ha cambiado
de una toma a la otra.
Esto está cambiando la manera de hacer ciencia,
de trabajar en astronomía,
en un espacio en donde el software y los algoritmos
que procesan esos datos
se vuelven tan vitales para la ciencia,
como los telescopios y las cámaras que se han construido.
Miles de nuevos descubrimientos
se harán realidad con este proyecto,
pero mencionaré solo dos teorías
sobre el origen y la evolución del universo,
que posiblemente sufrirán cambios
tras nuestro acceso
a todos estos datos.
En los últimos cinco años, la NASA ha descubierto
más de 1 000 sistemas planetarios
alrededor de estrellas cercanas,
pero los sistemas que encontramos
no se parecen mucho al nuestro,
y nos preguntamos
si esto se debe a que no estamos buscando bien,
o si hay algo especial o único
respecto a cómo se formó nuestro sistema solar.
Si queremos respuestas
necesitamos saber y entender
en detalle la historia de nuestro sistema solar;
los detalles son esenciales.
Si volvemos a fijarnos en el cielo
y en los asteroides que lo cruzan,
podemos verlos como los escombros del sistema solar.
Sus posiciones
son como la impronta de
tiempos remotos, cuando las órbitas de Neptuno y de Júpiter
se encontraban mucho más cerca del Sol,
y cuando estos gigantes migraron
esparciendo asteroides en su camino por el sistema solar.
Analizar los asteroides
es como un análisis forense,
de nuestro sistema solar.
Para hacer esto hace falta distancia
que obtenemos del movimiento,
y éste lo conseguimos por el acceso al tiempo.
Y ¿qué nos dice todo esto?
Si nos fijamos en estos pequeños asteroides amarillos
que revolotean por la pantalla,
vemos los que más rápido se mueven,
que son los que más cerca se encuentran de nuestro planeta.
Estos son los asteroides a los que un día
enviaremos astronaves en busca de minerales,
los mismos también que un día
podrían impactar contra la Tierra,
tal como ocurrió hace 60 millones de años
cuando desaparecieron los dinosauros,
o al principio del siglo pasado
cuando un asteroide arrasó
cerca de 2 000 km² de tundra siberiana,
o simplemente el año pasado cuando uno ardió en el cielo de Rusia
liberando una cantidad de energía igual a la de una pequeña bomba nuclear.
El análisis forense de nuestro sistema solar
no solo nos aporta información sobre el pasado,
sino que también predice el futuro, nuestro futuro.
Una vez que tengamos la distancia,
podremos ubicar los asteroides en sus hábitats naturales,
en órbitas alrededor del Sol.
Cada punto en esta imagen
corresponde a un asteroide real.
Hemos calculado su órbita analizando sus movimientos.
Los colores reflejan su composición;
secos y pedregosos en el centro,
ricos en agua y sencillos hacía el exterior,
siendo estos últimos los que, a lo mejor,
sembraron nuestros océanos y mares,
cuando bombardearon la Tierra en tiempos remotos.
Como el LSST será más sensible,
mejor equipado y con mayor resolución,
llegaremos a ver asteroides
que se encuentran más allá del centro de nuestro sistema solar,
más allá de las órbitas de Neptuno y Marte,
incluso los cometas y los asteroides que pueden existir
a casi un año luz de distancia del Sol.
A medida que aumentamos el detalle
en factores de 10 a 100 veces,
podremos responder a preguntas
sobre la existencia de otros planetas más allá de Neptuno,
o detectar asteroides en ruta
hacia la Tierra
mucho antes de que constituyan un peligro,
y poder averiguar si, quizás,
nuestro Sol se formó solo o en un enjambre de estrellas,
o si tal vez sus hermanos estelares
han influido en la formación del sistema solar,
motivo por el cual este tipo de sistemas sería tan poco frecuente.
Sobre la distancia y los cambios en nuestro universo,
la distancia equivale tanto a tiempo
como a cambios en el firmamento.
Cada 30 centímetros que nos acercamos
a un objeto lejano,
retrocedemos en el tiempo una mil millonésima parte de un segundo.
Esta idea, este concepto de retroceder en el tiempo
ha revolucionado nuestro entendimiento
acerca del universo, no una sino innumerables veces.
La primera vez ocurrió en 1929,
cuando un astrónomo llamado Edwin Hubble
demostró que el universo se expande,
lo que llevó a la teoría del Big Bang.
Sus observaciones fueron simples:
24 galaxias
y un dibujo hecho a mano.
La sola idea de que cuanto más lejana está una galaxia,
más rápido se aleja,
ha bastado para dar lugar a la cosmología moderna.
La segunda revolución tuvo lugar 70 años después
cuando dos grupos de astrónomos demostraron
que el universo no solo se expande sino que se acelera,
un descubrimiento tan sorprendente
como si al lanzar una pelota al aire
viéramos que cuanto más alto llega
más rápido se aleja.
Demostraron esto
midiendo la luminosidad de las supernovas,
y observando que esa luminosidad
se vuelve más débil con la distancia.
Las observaciones fueron más complejas
y requirieron nuevas tecnologías y nuevos telescopios,
porque las supernovas se encontraban
en galaxias 2 000 veces más lejanas
que las estudiadas por Hubble.
Se necesitaron 3 años para encontrar solo 42 supernovas,
porque en una galaxia explota
una supernova solo cada cien años.
Tres años para encontrar 42 supernovas
buscando en decenas de miles de galaxias.
Una vez se recolectaron los datos,
esto es lo que encontraron.
Aunque no parezca impresionante,
así es como se ve una revolución en la física:
una línea que predice la luminosidad de una supernova
encontrada a 11 mil millones de años luz,
junto a un puñado de puntitos que no encajan exactamente en esa línea.
Son pequeños cambios que generan enormes consecuencias.
Pequeños cambios que llevan a grandes descubrimientos,
como el planeta encontrado por Herschel.
Pequeños cambios que transforman por completo
nuestra percepción del universo.
42 supernovas, un tanto menos luminosas,
significa que se encuentran apenas un poco más lejos,
y eso requiere que el universo no solo tiene que estar expandiéndose,
sino que la expansión tiene que ser acelerada.
Se revela entonces un componente del universo
llamado energía oscura,
que es lo que produce esta expansión
y representa hasta un 68% del total de la energía
disponible hoy en el universo.
Entonces, ¿cómo será la próxima revolución?
Y ¿qué es la energía oscura y por qué existe?
Cada línea indica un modelo diferente
de lo que podría ser la energía oscura
y sus propiedades.
Todas son compatibles con los 42 puntos,
pero las teorías detrás de estas líneas
son completamente diferentes.
Algunos opinan que la energía oscura
cambia con el tiempo,
y que sus propiedades dependen
de dónde se mire en el cielo.
Otros imponen diferencias y cambios
en la física subatómica.
Mientras que otros observan a gran escala
y cambian la forma como trabajan la gravedad y la relatividad.
O dicen que nuestro universo es solo uno entre muchos,
parte de este misterioso multiuniverso.
Pero todas estas
ideas y teorías increíbles, ciertamente algunas un tanto descabelladas,
son coherentes con los 42 puntos.
Y bien, ¿entonces cómo pensamos darle sentido a todo esto
en los siguientes 10 años?
Imaginen que les doy un par de dados,
y les pido que averigüen
si están trucados o correctos.
Una sola tirada diría muy poco,
pero cuantas más veces rueden,
más información se recopila,
mayor certeza se logra,
no solo acerca de si están o no cargados,
sino también de cuánto y de qué manera.
Se tardó 3 años en descubrir 42 supernovas,
porque los telescopios con que contamos
solo pueden examinar una pequeña parte del firmamento.
Con el LSST, obtendremos una imagen
totalmente nueva del cielo de Chile, cada 3 noches.
En su primera noche de funcionamiento,
encontrará 10 veces más supernovas
que el número de las utilizadas para descubrir la energía oscura.
La cifra se multiplicará por mil
en los primeros 4 meses,
hasta un total de 1,5 millones de supernovas al final del proyecto.
Cada supernova representa un tiro de los dados,
y prueba cuáles teorías de la energía oscura
son consistentes y cuáles no.
Combinando estos datos sobre las supernovas
con otras mediciones cosmológicas,
eliminaremos gradualmente las diferentes ideas
y teorías de la energía oscura,
hasta que, con suerte, al final del proyecto, alrededor de 2030,
esperamos que una nueva teoría del universo,
una teoría fundamental para la física del universo,
tome forma progresivamente.
En muchos aspectos, las cuestiones que hemos presentado
son en realidad las más simples.
Es posible que no sepamos las respuestas
pero, por lo menos, sabemos cuáles son las preguntas.
Pero, si al buscar en decenas de miles de galaxias,
se han encontrado 42 supernovas
que nos revolucionaron la visión del universo,
cuando lleguemos a trabajar con miles de millones de galaxias,
¿cuántas veces más vamos a encontrar 42 puntos
que no encajen bien con lo esperado?
Al igual que el planeta descubierto por Herschel,
o la energía oscura,
o la mecánica cuántica o la relatividad general;
todas esas ideas surgieron
porque los datos no encajaban exactamente con lo que esperábamos.
Lo emocionante de la próxima década
en el campo de la astronomía
es que ni siquiera sabemos cuántas respuestas nos aguardan,
acerca de nuestros orígenes y nuestra evolución.
¿Cuántas respuestas están allá afuera,
respuestas para las que ni siquiera sabemos
qué preguntas hacer?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)